un beau jour
ou peut être une nuit
près d'un lac
je m'étais
endormi
quand soudain
semblant crever le ciel et venant de
nulle part
surgit dès
que le noir
je suis né le 30 novembre 1970 en italie
pourtant mes deux parents sont suisses
pourquoi en italie et bien parce que ma
mère a aidé mon père à s'évader de
prison et ils ont été se cacher
d'abord en france puis en italie et
c'est là que je suis né j'ai passé trois
ans là bas j'ai grandi auprès de ma mère
surtout je me souviens très peu de ces
trois premières années
c'est donc la naissance
ensuite
mes parents ont décidé de rentrer en
suisse parce que il voulait reconstituer
la famille ma soeur était resté chez
chez notre grand mère et pour ce faire
il fallait que mon père
à y purger sa peine et c'est ce qu'il a
fait ils sont rentrés en suisse mon père
est retourné en prison
et je me suis retrouvé avec ma maman une
grande soeur et une grand mère que je
connaissais très peu
une fois les problèmes résolus avec la
justice mon père est sorti de prison et
ils ont décidé de réunir la famille en
allant habiter dans un petit immeuble de
trois étages
et moi j'ai continué à grandir et j'ai
découvert un petit peu ma soeur un petit
peu mon père beaucoup ma mère avec
laquelle j'ai vécu mes premières années
tout le temps avec elle
lorsque on se retrouve en famille alors
qu'on a eu une vie un peu clandestine
c'est quelque chose de relativement
nouveau donc j'apprends un petit peu à
connaître mon père mais mon père attend
d'en savoir beaucoup c'est quelqu'un de
très travailleur de très joyeux
quelqu'un qui est
agréable vraiment les gens l'apprécient
sauf que souvent le soir il sort avec
ses amis et il boit et quand il rentre
au mieux de la nuit complètement ivre
le lendemain l'ambiance est absolument
glacial
et mon père crie pendant des heures sur
ma mère dans la cuisine ma soeur et moi
allons nous cacher et chacune dans notre
chambre complètement terrorisée
mais je continue à grandir et je suis
contente parce que j'ai ma maman ma
soeur et mon papa
un jour mon père
ma mère plutôt par faire des courses et
je me prépare pour l'accompagner et là
mon père me dit oh non reste avec moi me
laissent pas seul
je me dis bon moi je vais rester avec
lui j'ai cinq ans
ça m'apprendra peut-être un petit peu à
le connaître un peu un petit peu plus
donc ma mère s'en va une fois qu'elle
est partie mon père me demande de
s'asseoir sur ses genoux
je me dis c'est cool je vais avoir une
petite dose de câlins ça va être sympa
je vais proche de mon papa
alors il commence à poser ses mains peu
partout sur moi
et je vois son attitude changé je vois
ces yeux qui sortent de ces orbites je
vois presque la bave aux commissions des
lèvres je le vois avoir une respiration
qui devient haletante et là il pose sa
main sur mon sexe
ce jour là magie s'est arrêté
la construction s'est terminée
parce que quand on vit quelque chose
comme ça quand on a 5 ans on sait pas ce
qui se passe on se demande est ce que
c'est normal que tous les papas fonds
save leurs enfants
est-ce que je dois rien dire en même
temps je suis pas à l'aise j'aime pas je
déteste ça ça m'empêche de respirer j'ai
vraiment pas bien
et à l'intérieur depuis ce jour là
j'étais morte
mais mon corps a continué à grandir
mon intérieur est évident
ces actes ont duré jusqu'à mai 14 15 ans
là j'ai compris que c'était pas normal
que on commence à avoir un corps de
femme on commence à savoir ce que c'est
que la sexualité est là j'ai réalisé ce
qui m'était arrivé et je me suis dit non
c'est pas possible
et depuis j'ai eu tous les jours envie
de mourir je m'endormais le soir en
espérant pouvoir ne pas me réveiller le
lendemain matin
parce que je n'arrivais pas à vivre et
je savais pas vraiment pourquoi parce
que personne ne m'en avait parlé
donc je sais ce que je pouvais la
sidération l'addition la dissociation on
apprend à montrer qu'on va bien alors
qu'on va pas bien du tout et pourtant on
est encore une enfant
lorsque j'ai eu 17 ans je me suis dit
bon bah il faut que je parle je peux
plus garder ce secret en moi j'en parle
à quelqu'un de très proche et cette
personne me dit écoute ce secret on va
le garder pour nous
jamais on en parlera à personne jamais
je me suis dit bon ben je n'en parlerai
pas j'ai continué à avancer comme ça à
18 ans j'allais tellement mal que je me
suis dit bon j'ai besoin de me prendre
en main je vais voir un psychiatre et je
lui dis je vais pas bien je me dis mais
pourquoi vous n'allez pas bien je sais
pas je vais pas bien pas évident mais
vous pouvez pas m'en dire un peu plus je
lui dis ben
mon père n'a pas été correct avec moi
hélas il semble qu'il ait compris
parce qu'il a commencé à me demander des
détails que j'étais incapable de donner
mais j'ai vu sur son visage ce regard
qu'avait mon père quand j'étais petit
ces yeux qui sortent des orbites 7 bave
aux commissures des lèvres cette
respiration haletante
je me suis levé je suis parti
à 24 ans j'en parle enfin à ma mère
elle me dit mais qu'est ce que tu as ça
va jamais tu es toujours de mauvaise
humeur tu tires touche dans tout le
temps la gueule
alors que tu as tout pour être bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe et là elle me
tend une perche je la saisis et je lui
dis papy n'a pas été correct avec moi
j'ai pas eu besoin de lui donner de
détails je pense qu'elle a compris et je
pense que c'était tellement difficile
pour elle qu'elle s'est mis également
dans cette réel état de dissociation
pour pouvoir supporter le choc
et je me souviens très bien ce jour là
on devait se rendre à une fête de
famille elle me dit bon écoute on va là
la fête de famille et puis on en parlera
ce soir
alors toutes les deux on met notre
masque le sourire tout va bien alors
qu'on vient d'apprendre un truc énorme
elle vient d'apprendre un truc énorme on
va cette fête de famille le soir on se
réunit elle nous confronte mon père et
moi mon père ne dit rien il baisse les
yeux dit ni oui ni non et elle me dit
écoute laisse-moi de trois jours je vais
réfléchir et on verra ce qu'on va faire
au bout de trois jours elle me dit alors
écoute tu as 24 ans tu es une grande
fille maintenant tu ne risque plus rien
tu à l'abri alors j'ai deux solutions
soit je le quitte et à partir de là il
va faire encore plus de bêtises et ça va
être encore plus dur pour toi
soit je reste avec lui et là au moins je
peux surveiller ce qu'il fait et ce sera
plus prudent alors qu'est-ce que tu
choisis
disons maman j'ai 24 ans et par moi de
choisir pas ok je suis une adulte mais
non
mais je ne savais pas quoi lui dire et
je voulais pas qu'elle soit mal non plus
et je savais pas trop donc je lui dis
ben reste avec lui et il est resté avec
lui
je trouvais toujours pas le moyen
d'exister je savais pas comment
remplir le vide qui avaient en moi et je
savais pas trop ce qui se passait au moi
je comprenais pas puisque chaque fois
que j'en parlais je me retrouvais face à
un mur et personne ne pouvait m'aider
alors je me suis dit il faut que je
trouve le moyen d'exister je me suis
inscrite à l'élection de miss suisse
romande depuis 2006 alors que je n'étais
pas du tout du milieu je me suis
retrouvé balancé dans ce truc et j'ai
été élu et là du jour au lendemain
j'avais tous les yeux braqués sur moi
j'avais tous les photographes à mes
pieds je me suis sentie existé sauf que
très rapidement j'ai compris que c'était
très futile c'est très superficielle les
feux des projecteurs ça réchauffe pas du
tout pas l'intérieur en tout cas
donc j'ai toujours cherché ce moyen
d'avoir un peu de reconnaissance que je
ne trouvais pas
à 26 ans je vais voir un avocat
parce que j'en veux plus et je veux
déposer plainte contre mon père
c'était en 1996 ce
mon avocat étudie mon dossier il me dit
désolé à quelques mois près
il y à prescription vous ne pouvez rien
faire
ok bon bah je continue à aller mal je
suis des thérapies quand même on me dit
que je suis dépressif maniaco dépressifs
bipolaires on sort toutes sortes de
trucs et évidemment thérapie j'étais pas
capable de dire pourquoi j'allais mal
puisque moi-même je savais pas pourquoi
j'étais si mal puisque j'ai appris à
vivre avec à faire comme tout était
comme si tout était normal puisqu'il
fallait pas le montrer à ma mère il
fallait le montrer à personne donc
c'était une vie très joyeuse à
l'extérieur mais détruite à l'intérieur
lorsque j'ai eu presque 30 ans j'en
avais tellement marre
c'était tellement difficile
que pour
supporter la douleur souvent je me
taillader les attendra pour voir couler
le sang pour que la douleur deviennent
réelles sap a une douleur simplement
intérieur j'avais besoin de la voir de
sentir de savoir pourquoi j'avais mal
mais je trouvais pas de réponse
alors j'ai décidé d'en finir avec la vie
et je me suis raté
j'ai passé quelques jours dans le coma à
l'hôpital et quand je me suis réveillé
ma première réaction c'était de dire
mais pourquoi je suis encore là
donc ça a toujours été une destruction
une impossibilité de vivre une
difficulté à m'associer à des proches
parce que dès que je suis proche c'est
dangereux mais j'ai quand même essayé
d'avoir une vie normale alors je me suis
marié je me suis dit tiens je vais
essayer de faire comme tout le monde vu
que je fais semblant mais je vais faire
semblant aussi un est à 36 ans j'ai eu
un petit garçon et là c'était la
révélation parce que pour la première
fois de ma vie j'avais dans mes bras un
être vivant un être humain en qui je
pouvais avoir totale confiance et
c'était absolument magnifique
évidemment mon mariage a pris l'eau mais
j'ai remis le couvert juste après et
j'ai une petite fille qui a maintenant
quatre ans est à nouveau un deuxième
être sur cette terre en qui je peux
avoir totale confiance
il ya deux ans j'ai appris que mon père
continuait ses agissements j'avais
espéré que non mais au fond de moi je
sentais qu'il y avait quand même quelque
chose de pas normal
et là c'était là derrière dégringolade
et je me suis rendu compte que il y
avait des associations qui avait des
gens qui étaient là pour aider qu'ils
avaient des thérapeutes formés à ce
genre de problème
et je me suis dirigé vers ces gens là
pour essayer de trouver du soutien
et j'ai donné un peu de force à cette
dernière petite victime de déposer
plainte il l'a fait j'en suis très fier
j'ai déposé ma plainte en même temps que
lui et elle a été elle a été entendue
alors si celui-là ce soir c'est pas pour
me plaindre c'est simplement pour vous
dire que
si vous faites partie de ces gens là si
vous avez un traumatisme si vous avez
été vécu quelque chose de très difficile
ne gardez pas ça en vous il faut vider
l'abcès il faut déposer le pardon au
bord de la route et puis essayer de
continuer à avancer peut importer des
gars vous êtes pas responsable des
dégâts dont fait le déjà une libération
ensuite
c'est important de prévenir nos enfants
et je trouve que il devrait être
obligatoire d'avoir au moins un cours
dans une vie d'un enfant pour savoir que
papa ou maman ou tonton ou tata ou le
frère n'a pas le droit de toucher les
endroits qui sont à toi sur ton corps
c'est intime personne n'a le droit
si j'avais eu ça moi j'aurais peut-être
pu dire non un enfant averti saura
peut-être dire non
et puis juste imaginer que quand vous
entrez dans une classe là maintenant
vous ouvrez la porte de la classe où
vous rentrez ya au moins un enfant en ce
moment qu'est victimes d'abus sexuels
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose à faire
et par rapport à la prescription ce que
je voulais dire aussi c'est que c'est
très bien depuis 2008 les actes d'ordre
sexuels sur les enfants sont
imprescriptibles
mais qu'en est il des anciennes victimes
quand on connaît les problèmes de la
mémoire traumatique de la mémoire rom
amnésique de la destruction qui se fait
à l'intérieur du cerveau c'est
scientifiquement prouvé lorsque vous
vivez un acte d'ordre sexuel lorsque
vous êtes un enfant vous avez une partie
du cerveau qui est détruite alors après
il faut avancer et apprendre aviva vrai
avec c'est comme s'il vous manque une
jambe
vous continuez à avancer mais pour
avancer vous mettez une prothèse mais
vous marcherait jamais comme quelqu'un
qui a deux jambes et là c'est la même
chose il manque quelque chose au cerveau
pour pouvoir avancer de manière logique
le cerveau n'est plus un il a été
détruit et souvent les gens parlent des
années plus tard parce que comme moi par
exemple j'ai toujours été mal je savais
pas pourquoi j'étais mal c'est quand
j'ai compris pourquoi j'étais si mal que
j'ai pu me prendre en main
et à les voir des spécialistes pour
soigner ce genre de problème alors je
pense pas qu'on puisse aller bien mais
je pense qu'on peut aller mieux et ça il
faut pas il faut pas le rater et la
prescription
il faudrait actuellement quelqu'un qui
est âgé de 28 ans et plus n'a pas la
possibilité de se faire entendre par la
justice il faut absolument qu'ils aient
une imprescriptibilité rétroactive pour
tout le monde pour tout le monde
donc ce que je voulais vous dire ce soir
c'est ici c'est qu'à tout le monde
camille croit on a tous une croix une
grande une petite une lourde une légère
on a des traumatismes on en a pas mais
on a tous vécu ici dans cette salle vous
avez tous vécu quelque chose de
difficile ce que j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est que vous avez eu la chance de
venir sur cette terre vous avez la
chance de naître donc vous n'avez qu'une
seule vie et cette vie vous appartient
rien qu'à vous personne n'a le droit de
vous la voler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]